welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Jackson a professor of
Portuguese at Yale University his
research interests include Portuguese
and Brazilian literature's commotions
machado de assis
fernando pessoa modernist vanguard
estándar arts literature Portuguese
culture in Asia and ethnomusicology
today we'll talk with professor Jackson
about his new book entitled machado de
assis a literary life
welcome professor Jackson thank you very
much well let's start by having you tell
us who this man was who is machado
machado de assis
is Brazil's greatest writer and all of
Latin America's greatest writer in the
end of the 19th the beginning of the
20th century he had a very long literary
life a formative period of some 25 years
where he wrote a journalism translated
plays was very active and resonated and
in the last thirty years where he
produced the novels for which and short
stories for which he's most known he was
a man of letters in every sense he wrote
in practically every genre novel short
story play journalism he did
translations of Victor Hugo of
Shakespeare and he became the preeminent
man of letters of his time in Brazil and
his novels that are considered now some
of the great novels of the end of the
19th century okay and tell us about your
book and what your goal was in writing
it so the goal of my book was to promote
Machado and present Machado as a great
writer of his time in the company of the
other European and world prose writers
of the end of the 19th century and what
were some of his contemporaries so he's
mentioned along with Henry James with
Proust with dust of yesica Gogol and of
course in the Burin Peninsula with
Esther de chaos and some of the other
prose writers he had translated Dickens
so he really fits in to the great
realist writers at the end of the
nineteenth century except that he
changed that whole tradition and he can
be seen and one of the objects of my
book is to present him as in a way the
inventor of the modernist novel and my
prose okay
very interesting so this he did by
changing a receive tradition he was a
great reader he read everything and his
works incorporate shall I say traces of
everything that he read but there
changed to be applied to a Brazilian
situation and also put across with his
characteristic humor and irony and his
narrative stance now I know you're a big
fan and I am curious what specifically
was it about
Machado that drew you to him I think
he's the first author I read when I
started studying Portuguese and the
fascination stayed with me and of course
I've taken a number of seminars and
continue to read Machado over the years
but his novels are so ingenious in a way
that they're sort of prime material that
people who do Portuguese study the
acquaintance with Machado sees through
translation actually had an early phase
in the 1950s and 60s a classical scholar
at UCLA named Helen Caldwell translated
three of his novels in a number of short
stories and did two books of
interpretation published in 1960 and
1970 William Grossman another translator
did the posthumous memoirs of bras Kubis
which is an early novel and a early
edition and these were to some extent
widely read at the time I had a Yale
alumnus who returned to take a course
with me after he had graduated and he
had read these translations in the 60s
and thought it was so unusual to have a
course available on Michoud JC's that he
came to read them again now we've come
to another cycle there are new
translations of a lot of the major
novels and the oxford latin american
library and there's been quite a lot of
renewed attention to Michelle Jesse's I
think the prominence of Brazil and
recent news has helped to promote that
and also there are a number of online
sites where you can access the works of
the complete works of Machado
and studies of him as well so that now
there's a new attention to mahadji Aziz
and our own Harold Bloom of course as
mentioned Machado is one of the great
authors of the Western tradition and
part of the objective of my book also is
to promote the incorporation of Machado
into the courses of comparative
literature and into the Canon let's say
of the world's major authors so if we
had to pick one of his works for
instance a novel perhaps give us a bit
of detail about it and overview so yes
he wrote four early novels in the 1870s
that are considered romantic but they
actually do have many characteristics of
what's called his mature fiction and
that consists of five novels starting in
1880 with the posthumous memoirs of bras
Kubus which has the interesting conceit
that the author has written the book
after death right then there's a an
interesting discussion among readers of
Machado whether that's his greatest
novel or whether it's dongha's Muro
which is a novel he wrote in 1900 which
is the retrospective memoirs of another
character so those two are generally
considered his greatest novels he also
wrote Kinkos bored whaha novel in 1890
was sort of a continuation of the first
and two final novels written in the 20th
century by a character named conselheiro
ideas
the interesting thing about all these
novels which is also fascinating for
readers is that they're not written by
machado de assis they're written by the
main characters who are their narratives
of their own memoirs and generally
written either retrospectively at a
point in old age or in the first one
after death so we have brass Kubus who's
dead and writing his memoirs we have
been to Santiago who's an old man
recalling the incidents of his earlier
life and justifying them and we have
councilor ideas who's a retired diplomat
who comes back to Rio after a long
career to face death but to interact
with the city of his memory mm-hmm okay
very interesting so Machado has a very
large body of work and also many have
written about him as well how did you go
about doing the research for your book
so the bibliography on Machado
of course mostly in Portuguese is
immense there's a 1955 work of
bibliography on Machado which is an
enormous volume so fortunately the you
know library is pretty good so I was
able to find a number of crucial
interpretations in Machado but that was
the question how to approach Machado now
in view of all of the books written
about him over time really from the 30s
to the present so actually I found
several accounts to be very useful one
of a curious Brazilian scholar named
Agra peda greco who knew all of Machado
sources these are this is a time when
people read everything there's no TV so
he says so this is from here and there
and even makes a curious comment when he
says I wish I had read Machado when I
was much younger because then I wouldn't
know on any of this and it would all
seem fresh and direct so that was a help
to me in showing how Machado had pieced
together sources from everything that he
read from different literature's
classical sources history and so forth
to compile his diverse narratives and
his style so earlier you had mentioned
that he's becoming more popular up until
this point I think he's been relatively
unknown even though there is such a huge
volume of writing about him why do you
think it is is his works translated into
English for instance so that's an
interesting question because after Helen
Caldwell there were a number of American
critics who discovered machado de assis
susan sontag wrote a long essay in the
new yorker that became very well known
Michael wood at Princeton John Barth the
author mentioned a lot of Machado and
Woody Allen write comments on machado de
assis
so it's not that he's unknown but I
would say that he was a lesser read and
when these translations came out they
wouldn't necessarily stay in print and I
think part of the problem and this is
pointing out is that there wasn't enough
criticism there was enough writing about
Machado that was available for people to
know more about him rather than other
than just the translations that were on
the market so I think we still need
books about machado de assis and
interpretations of Machado as a way of
helping students and other readers
to be able to fully appreciate the works
that are now in translation before them
alright and in his writing he employed a
number of key principles let's talk a
little bit about that so one of the
things that's most modern about his
novels is its narrative strategy and is
talking to the reader so we assume most
of his readers at the time were female
readers in Rio and he University
dialogues with them so well there was a
very small literate class at the time
and this was the Brazilian Empire and so
there wasn't that amount of literature
in Brazil at the time so he's very aware
that his readers maybe of course female
readers at home from this class and he
teases them plays with them to a large
extent and will say oh as my reader
knows and then he'll say the reader who
remembers chapter two will know that you
know so you have to go back to chapter
two and at one point Roz Kubus accuses
the reader and says the greatest defect
of my book is you reader right you're
the one who's keeping my book from being
everything it should be so the dialogue
with the reader is very important and it
makes the reader than part of the
process of the actual construction our
reading of the book and that's one of
his most innovative narrative features
and the other is using small chapters
some of which are put together only with
graphic signs so he's quite experimental
and inventive to that extent there's one
chapter that's just an epitaph on a
tombstone so in other words he's one of
the first authors to use a kind of what
shall I say Multimedia different
narrative structure semiotic approach to
putting the the novel together okay and
then conclusions what you conclude in
the book what I conclude in the book
Machado worked a lot with theater in his
early life he was very impressed with
the great actresses and actors who came
to Brazil there were Italian
Shakespearean actors who came in the
1870s there were great Sopranos who sang
with the operas mostly Italian that were
that were produced in Brazil and really
quite soon after their premieres in
Italy and actually one of the points I
make is that
the great heroines and Machado's novels
he created great female characters are
based to a certain extent probably on
these famous Sopranos whom he saw and
wrote about in Brazil but to a certain
extent he constructs in his novel a
theater of the world which is the city
of Regina - of his time the world of the
Empire as if it were to a certain extent
an opera on stage right so that opera
techniques of wretched Atif of dialog of
scenes and so forth really I think
helped to form and sustain his literary
works
so my last conclusion or my chapter is
called Machado and the spectacle of the
world which is the idea of the author
who is the observer of the very
theatrical performance of the world of
real generator that he constructs and
like another a number of other famous
authors he never left the city of
regenitive practically so the city was
to a certain extent his universe that he
knew very well and if one wanted to get
their feet wet for the first time we
with Machado what would you suggest they
read so there have been a number of new
translations of his short stories he was
a master of the short story from and so
the translations in English start with
the devil's Church the chapter of hats
there are a number of new volumes of
short stories that would be a very good
place to start are some of the later
trends the latest translations of his
novels I would say the posthumous
memoirs of bras Cuba's are Donkers
moo-hoo very famous works and open to
different kinds of interpretations so
the reader could jump right in and then
try to figure out what's going on very
exciting David thank you so much for
being here with us thank you for the
invitation some of your work very good
for more information about Professor
Jackson and his research please visit
our website at Yale that edu slash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale